let's see if we can figure out what 256
to the 4 7 power divided by 2
to the 4
7 power is and like always pause the
video and see if you can figure this out
all right let's work through this
together and at first you might find
this kind of daunting especially when
you see something like 2 to the 4 7
power is that even that's not going to
be a whole number how do i how do i do
this especially without a calculator and
i should have said do this without a
calculator but then the key is to to see
to see that we can use our exponent
properties to simplify this a little bit
so that we can do this on paper and the
main property that might jump out at you
is if i have something
if i have if i have x
to the a power
over
y
to the a power this is the same thing as
x over y
to the a power and our situation right
over here 256 would be x 2 would be y
and then a is 4 7. so we can rewrite
this this is going to be equal to
this is equal to 256
over 2
to the 4
7 power and so this is nice we're
already able to simplify this because we
know 256 divided by 2 is 128.
so this is 128
to the 4
7 power
now this might also seem a little bit
difficult how do i raise 128 to a
fractional power but we just have to
remind ourselves this is the same thing
this is the same thing as 128 to the
one-seventh power
then raised to the 4th power we could
also view it the other way around we
could say that this is also 128
to the 4th
to the 4th power and then raise that to
the 1 7th but multiplying 128 four times
that's going to be very computationally
intensive and then we have to find the
seventh root of that that seems pretty
difficult so we don't want to go in that
way but if we can get the smaller number
first what is 128 to the 7 to the 1 7
power then that might be easier to raise
to the fourth power now when you look at
this and knowing that probably
the question writer in this case i'm the
person who presented with you is telling
you that you're not going to use a
calculator it's a pretty good clue that
all right this is probably going to be a
this is probably going to be something
that i can figure out on my own and you
might recognize 128 as a power of 2 and
maybe 2 to the 7th is 128 and we can
verify that
so let's see
2 to the first is 2
128 2 times 2 is 4 times 2 is 8 times 2
is 16 times 2 is 32 times 2 is 64 times
2 is 128. so 2 to the 7th power is equal
to 1 28. or another way of saying this
exact same thing is that 128
128 is equal to
or 128 to the one seventh power
is equal to two or you could even say
that the seventh root
the seventh root of 128 is equal
is equal to two
so we can simplify this this is 2. so
our whole expression is now just 2 to
the 4th power
well that's just 2 times 2 times 2 times
2.
so that's 2
to the 4th power
2 to the 4th power which is just going
to be equal to 16. that's 2 times 2
times 2 times 2 right over there and so
we're done this crazy complicated
looking expression it is simplified to
16.